also wir haben jetzt hier eine schöne
weiße wand genauso wie der junge von dem
produktbild den ich immer kurzer film
für euch ein wenden werde
[Musik]
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
bei einem neuen video
heute haben wir schon das dritte video
aus der alex wiebusch woche wir haben
hier wieder neues produkt und ich muss
sagen heute freue ich mich noch einmal
ganz besonders weil ich habe überhaupt
keine ahnung was das kann und ich wusste
nicht mal dazu es gibt wahrscheinlich
die meisten von euch auch nicht ich habe
es direkt bestellt es ist zum glück auch
schon angekommen
und ihr habt sie wahrscheinlich auch
schon gesehen
um was es sich handeln markte vor
schluss gehen auch ganz wichtig gestern
und vorgestern haben auch schon ein
video gedacht einmal eine kettensäge und
playstation 4 controller
zwar fällt trotzdem mit dem controller
weil hier die noch nicht gesehen habt
schaut ihr euch auf jeden fall nach
diesem video an
und wie immer habt ihr auch die chance
dieses produkt zu gewinnen und oben
drauf legt dann wie jeden tag noch den
100 euro gutschein
das heißt wenn ihr sagt ich will
mitmachen einfach im kommentar schreiben
unter dieses video was ist scheißegal
und abonnent von einem klar sein es ist
auch für uns wichtig dann würde ich
sagen nachdem jetzt alle ordentlich auf
gefällt mir gedrückt hat will ich gar
nicht lange her da war und wir fangen
einfach mal an also nur ein bisschen
habe ich schon ausgemacht ja also so
sieht's aus finde ich eigentlich
ziemlich professionell ich muss betont
dass er jetzt keine 50 euro gekostet
oder so ich glaube es waren 17 euro oder
14 euro ein von beiden weiß vielleicht
mal nachschauen also der erste eindruck
ist auf jeden fall nicht schlecht
gesteht und wird auch alles auf ein
wir machen das ganze mal auf also
einiges an schutzfolie euro ist noch so
viel dass sich also ich muss sagen diese
luft pusten
ich mag diese garantieren wir dann
anzahl der aufgabe und das ist auch
schon das massage kit falls man das so
fühlt sich richtig gut an
hier haben wir noch ein weiteres lade
das sieht mir aus wie als wert fürs auto
also diese zigarettenanzünder die man in
den meisten autos hat das team geben
vermutlich um sich beim autofahren
massieren zu lassen wenn es heute schon
im auto wird integriert ist
das habe ich leider nicht also an sich
für nicht cool
hier haben wir noch in der beschreibung
[Musik]
wahrscheinlich also wo ist die
fernbedienung könnte ist eine
fernsteuerung keine ahnung die
fernsteuerungen sollte bestimmt ebenso
darin auch mit dabei sein als ich würde
sagen bevor wir weiter machen schauen
sonst das produkt erst mal ein bisschen
genauer an
ist ja ganz wichtig wir schauen uns die
rezension an ihr könnt ich muss
allerdings sagen es hat sich nicht nur
zum billigprodukt für 14 euro angeführt
beim auspacken sondern europa gastiert
in der hand hat ich schätze deutlich
teurer eigentlich wenn ich den preis
jetzt nicht wissen
aber gut wir schauen ist die rezension
und so weiter letztere aber das war ja
leute also herzlich willkommen auch von
meiner seite hier im offiziellen alex w
rezensions studio ich bin heute ihr
vertreter und möchte immer das produkt
etwas näher bringen
das heiße leute ich habe genau dieses
produkt hier bestellt wie sehr junge
hier hat mich so nett angelächelt da
muss ich einfach zugreifen und jetzt
sehe ich gerade auch schon dass das
keine veranstaltung hat sondern die
fernsteuerung mit auf dem er will hier
drauf ist also wir haben ja ein new
electric shiatsu das tier zu niedrig
schauder body massage mit healthcare
black bis ihr könnt sehr gemein die
kommentare schreiben
so was schon mal gesehen habt ich vorher
noch nie ich habe mich einmal gefragt er
gibt sich sondern massier maschine außer
halt diese stühle halt irgendwie so ein
ding was einmassiert weil ich wirklich
sehr sehr gerne passiert werde aber habe
ich so noch nie gesehen
ich habe dafür anscheinend 13 euro
bezahlt ich habe danach gesucht also ich
habe 13 euro dafür bezahlt + 8 euro
versand halte man kann sich halt einmal
den schultern
am rücken und so an der hüfte massieren
lassen wir schauen uns mal zusammen die
bewertung an
alles klar kids war weiß ich bescheid
auch danke für das foto das dubai gelegt
hast veranschaulicht das ganze natürlich
gleich doppelt tolle ware funktioniert
einwandfrei und sehr schnell angekommen
wieder gerne superschnell weniger als
eine woche danke schnell barbara gut
kann ich nur empfehlen also die meisten
geben hier halt wirklich fünf sterne was
ihr schon mal gut ist schneller als die
polizei erlaubt mir kam es auch extrem
schnell an und ich bin jetzt einfach mal
gespannt ich würde es schnellstmöglich
testen und euch hier gar nicht weiter
mit irgendeinem müll bequatschen man
kann es auch in beige auswählen was ich
allerdings witzig fand dieser junge hier
der guckt auf jedem bild unterschiedlich
also es gibt verschiedene angebote
hier seien noch manchmal kostet 18 euro
manchmal nur 13 mal ein kleiner
vergleich so ein massagegerät kostet zum
beispiel auf amazon dann gleich schon 60
euro also soviel hier von meiner seite
und wir sehen uns wieder
bis gleich sodass ich bin jetzt wirklich
mal gespannt ob ich gleich sagen werde
hiervon massiert zu werden fühlt sich
kulant
cool dass falsches wort fühlt sich geil
an oder halt nicht so weit
es kann ja auch sein das ist einfach
dass man es so gar nicht wirklich spürt
also hier kann man das ganze mit
verschiedenen funktionen anscheinend
steuer und so legt man das datum wenn
ich mich jetzt nicht eingehen dann die
arme durch und dann legt das
wahrscheinlich los genau so kann man
sich dann auch hier diesen rücken wenn
sich geglaubt und sich massieren lassen
und das ganze wahrscheinlich gerade
ziemlich happig aus jetzt ist mir
aufgefallen ich idiot hab's ja noch gar
nicht aufgeladen
das müssen wir erst mal machen ach nee
warten wahrscheinlich muss eleganter
zweitürer steckdose
ich suche mal kurz eine steckdose ich
habe leider heute kein kameramann ich
bitte das zu entschuldigen ich habe das
ganze jetzt hier eingesteckt und man
braucht wirklich strom dafür das ist
halt funktioniert also wir haben hier
leider keinen akku den mann aufladen
kann
aber ist ja gar nicht schlimm dafür auch
hier diesem auto steckt also wir haben
jetzt eine schöne weiße wand genauso wie
der junge von dem produktbild den ich
immer kurz auch schön für euch ein
viertel werde so jetzt kann ich euch das
ganze mal kurz erklären wir drücken hier
einfach mal auf den schalter dann werdet
ihr sehen
das geht an dreht sich und leuchtet
dabei sogar
also muss ich sagen ich bin immer noch
begeistert auch generell hiervon von
diesem polster und so gefällt mir
richtig gut dann kann man es natürlich
einmal langsamer machen und wir können
doch wieder schneller machen
das heißt wir haben insgesamt noch mal
kurz aus wir insgesamt drei stufen die
man verstehen kann hier kann man auch
das licht an und ausschalten hier auch
mit diesem dreh symbol kann man ganz
einfach die richtung wechseln ich lege
mir das jetzt einfach mal um das ist
falsch macht richtig rum unreif ich hier
rein
auch wenn das jetzt nicht das ist jetzt
hier meinen guten bricht okay leute a321
[Musik]
ein bisschen mal ein bisschen weiter
bisschen weiter ein bisschen rechts
weiter da bin ich ein bisschen verspannt
genau genau da
[Musik]
jetzt mal es passiert ja gerade noch
meinen rücken da ein bisschen jetzt
passiert dann noch mal ganz vorn ganz
waren das wollte ich sagen
also ich bin keine maßstab danke ich
musste sagen gestern war ich schon sehr
begeistert von der produkt und heute bin
ich wieder
also es gibt keinen punkt den ich jetzt
hier oder den ich mir besser vorstellen
könnte sagen wir es mal so ich meine das
ding haus 13 euro wenn man es jetzt
stärker haben möchte zieht man einfach
hier unten dran wenn man es ein bisschen
lockerer haben möchte dass wir ein
bisschen lockerer es ist für jeden
individuell einstellbar und das gefällt
mir wirklich gut also ich denke ich
jetzt mal abends so vom pc gucken wir
genau was an und hat nicht eilig weil
das ja verlosen heute das sind das
produkt 13
ja leute mir ist aufgefallen
ich habe noch gar kein ende gemacht ich
habe das video jetzt auch schon soweit
fertig gestellt und ich muss sagen es
ist eins meiner persönlichen
lieblingsvideos von mir selber was so
risch betrifft also wirklich den mega
mega cool das produkt kann man
eigentlich nur weiterempfehlen ich bin
wirklich also das hat mich voll ungarn
heute das ist so geil ist wenn ihr mir
das nicht glauben können nimmt auf jeden
fall am gewinnspiel teil schreibt einen
kommentar unter dieses video schreibt 1
kommentar unter dieses video und
abonniert den kanal und dann habt ihr
die chance das ding hier und 100 euro
gutschein zu gewinnen alle gewinner
werden am 25.12 bekannt gegeben auf
youtube und auf instagram auf unserem
könnt ihr mir gerne folgen da es sich
alex w ansonsten sehen wir uns morgen
natürlich um die gleiche uhrzeit 19 uhr
jeden tag gibt es jetzt ein neues video
in der alex wie frisch woche wieder und
mal schauen was ist dann das das ding
ballerina jetzt geht's richtig aber mal
schauen was es dann kein produkt ist
vielleicht wird es ja noch cooler als
das hier
wir werden sehen dank fürs zuschauen und
checkt auf jeden fall die videos von
gestern und vorgestern habt weil die
sind fast genauso cool also leute immer
noch hier förderstufe ja